So far, we've seen how a developer might interact with the
file system to the positioned based or cursor based aisle. It's
also possible, however, to interact with a file in a way
that let's us treat it just like memory. As before, we
begin by opening a file with the open procedure. Instead of
using read and write on the file, however, we call mmap.
This returns a pointer to a region of memory that we
can manipulate in our code. And eventually, whatever changes we make
to the memory, get reflected in the file. When we're done with the file, we
call munmap, which syncs the contents of memory with the file and then frees up
the memory. And lastly, we can close
the file as before. Again, I'm skipping over
most of the details here so that you
can learn them through a little programming exercise.